also in there and help handle some
of the bigger more powerful forwards
of this Carolina team Here Comes Andre
snov a pass in front terrifying in denied
by brw another stop as well as brw a third
consecutive save there he's under siege but
answering the Bell after this opportunity was
created by speet aop he's able to get through
the checks now the pass through peon stick
comes out to and look at the J through their
lineup off the draw here's a shot right on BR
the save rebound me and the Hurricanes were two
for two on the power play on Saturday against
Buffalo here's another save from brussa and
this time he hangs on no rebound here's terrain
looking cross ice feed back to Brent Burns pass
a one-time and BR is sharp to start this one off
tonight yeah sure feed over to Seth Jarvis pnov
back to Burns who takes a look Terin sends it back
burns the onetime and out to challenge was Lauren
brah Burns over to tavin he slides it out front
that's handled by Guston but the puck is not out
Terrain in front as well and it was off of Jarvis
that was Sebastian AO who now has the puck Jarvis
parked out front AO down low tavine and the puck
takes a bounce off the left pad of bran those pads
the new ones they look real good they're getting
worked in so far I can tell you that facing a lot
of rubber here oh awesome news about the rider
signing here's Terra who takes a look a pass down
L back to Terra BR to save the net is off as sheay
went into the post that's 10 nothing here in the
early going chances Galore but BR with the answer
so far here on Monday night hockey the point PES
shot hits a body Dylan and all of a sudden a
chance for C Yi was trying to jaming home and
it's covered up by bris as Martin NES is racing to
the net a pass in front Drury got his stick on it
Puck still available here's pesi all of a sudden
wrist shot bruss the save without a stick off the
Stick of terraine and a bump that is taken by Cami
quickly on his feet smetch a CER brell right arm
save directed that back another good stop from
the tender had some Pace on that shot that would
have Stu here's shy Lee to Kyle Conor dishing it
front no shot here it is and listen to that crowd
here the Jets faithful at the Canada Life Center
in celebration and for Andy that's not easy either
no it's not going almost 17 minutes without a shot
on net and he made a good left P save there here's
a race for the pck Nikolai elers is in he waits
Kyle cter [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music]
scor what a time to score after being outshot
heavily Kyle Connor scores after being goulis
and six straight minutes and 32 seconds into the
period the Jets transition quickly up the middle
of the ice it looks like a two onone Conor gets
a step on Bunting and when he does so he makes no
mistake that's a scary proposition you face
one shot in about 16 and a half minutes and
now you've got one of the best goal scorers
in the game bearing down on you he buries it
Conor with his 15th of the season coming from
eers and shley so the top line for the Jets
answering and answering once again there is
see if they can put another piece of rubber
here on rant that was priceless here's Kyle
Conor navigating through shot from the slot
right ped off from Rand Jarvis One Touch
pass caught kenami good stick handling in
the bo there as caught kenami finds snov he
pulled back the Wier handled by [Applause]
BR here's Josh Morrison gradually moving up
delardi makes a move driving to the net a
pass it takes a bounce and R was ready boun off P
went right towards rant and he made a great there
reacting quickly Mark shley has a look still the
Pu on his stick now to the point NES is out of
the box Kyle Connor surveys puts it on target
flirty rebound shle rebound and the save for
moranta here now is Drury moving in drops it off
a shot on net brwa starting off right where he
left off from no rebound on that one a lot of
Team success so far more dep in the Jets line
up rari's injured right nowelo arer rebound
available R far out of the net still made the
stop another opportunity now this time organ
Baron and a rejection from rant and he's going
to Coral this one and cover up he didn't think
they could come out and have a period like they
did at first I'm sure they heard something
hereti and the save and he vacuums up that
Pucket theyes from the corner a pass all the way
over to Brent Burns Burns into traffic martinis
being pressured by Larry Burns open off the
iron controlling in his own end Bren Burns
back over towards slaven who's moved up got
past Appleton slaven is in centering pass off
the outside of the net and Jordan Stall on that
rebound Martin coming driving and that pass is
in front through everyone and heers takes it
drops it back shley to Conor back to sh Poli
centering P heers top shelf [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music] goal Nikolai eers with his
seventh of the season has the Winnipeg Jets up by
two this is simply fantastic the movement of this
Puck goes Conor eers between the legs to shley oh
yeah I'll just drop it back to Conor back to shley
and eers does such a great job here rather than
rushing towards the net he Paces himself back to
the high slot where there is no coverage he gets
it on and off the stick in the hurry with great
accuracy and the Winnipeg Jets have a two nothing
lead now flying through was just the pass too far
for or last minute of play here in the second
period CH field slopper drop around to T and
they score and there it is for Martin NES as the
hurricanes have cut the lead in half it goes in
off of Dylan Dello and we'll get back to that in a
sec but it was Seth Jarvis a short time thereafter
as this Puck has failed to be cleared Nas is in
there and you'll see it come to the right side of
your screen deelo where's number two he's trying
to defend against the wp around and instead it's
nasu bounc the puck off his skate and in and
right away Dello looking up as to say hey man
I tried but stepped up a notch and beat orof
tried to flip it to the forehand here now is
dimetri orof pass it for brah a fantastic effort
to keep that one out for bris with another Save
A Little Help from pong 2-1 jet us about this
morning important than the ex's and O's for
this team and here now Off to the Races is Kyle
Conor looking for insurance robbery from anant AC
two opportunities for Connor going 38 km per hour
all the way to the other side eers couldn't get
the puck away slaven has it moving it to teramind
and downlo jvis for the Jets both thwarted Jarvis
with a chance to tidy tried to flip it over
just missed the Hurricanes win the drop sh
the one timer off the back boards and guess
who has it once again my goodness has he been
great tonight that's going to do it what a treat
this one's been the Jets Victorious two to one